hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Sunday and as I'm pre
recording this on a Thursday I have no
idea how the game on Saturday went the
match between Croatia and Russia I I
mean I do hope we won but in case we
lost you know congratulations to Russia
you have an excellent team now about
this game again it's a rashid medina of
fez medina of game to brighten your day
i was played in 1966 and he faces a
russian international master of light
emitted me tree which sergievsky and
it's quite weird i mean i couldn't find
a single photo of lighting with severe
sky I mean I'm in search the Russian
with Wikipedia perhaps I I you know
missed it somehow but I couldn't find a
single reference to him and he was a
very active player he played for his
entire life and I mean he was a very
strong international master so it's very
odd that I couldn't find any reference
to him if any of you are able to do so
or you know have a link to his photo do
share and I will put all of it in the
description below so people can check it
out so let's see the game we have E 4
and C 5 the Sicilian defence Knight to
f3 d6 d4 C capture son d4 Knight
captures and V 4 and a 6 so the con
variation and as we've just checked out
the 1936 Moscow international tournament
you will saw that a game a couple Blanca
vs Elia Brahma witch hunt so this is a
variation named after him so there you
have it your vast knowledge has just
been increased nice to see three Queen
to c7 and Bishop to e2 we have Knight to
f6 castles by Rasheed knife to c6 and
Bishop to e3 now so simply just
developing a transposing into the
bathroom variation of the time on of and
Bishop to b4 Bishop to b4 is a move that
allows white perhaps a bit too much here
Rasheed immediately plays Knight
captures on c6 b captures on c6 and
queen to d4 now forcing sergievsky to
decide what to do with the bishop on b4
either to capture the night or to go
back maybe the Bishop to e7 or Bishop to
d6
c5 is a move that does
seem all that natural I mean why would
you block your bishop urine before but
yeah the engine actually very much
enjoys this move and pretty much says it
forces a draw after we move the Queen
now Bishop to b7 attacking d4 pawn and
after a three attacking the bishop now
comes c4 attacking the Queen captures
captures captures now comes Bishop
captures pawn captures and simply Bishop
captures here the material is equal and
the black's pawn structure is even
better so black actually very much
enjoys a c5 in this position the engine
but in the game rush to d6 was played
attacking the h2 pawn and here comes F
for protecting h2 and also preparing a
5-2 win material here he five black
pushes himself we have Queen d2 he
captures on f4 Bishop captures we have
Bishop captures rook captures and now d6
and here comes Rock a to d1 attacking
the the weak d7 pawn
d6 pawn and black has to defend it via
King to e7 which was played in the game
and here rook to F to it this might seem
like a very strange move - why would no
reverse gear Rashid move back with with
a piece but it's actually an attacking
move
Rashid wants to centralize his Queen
with Queen to d4 but he doesn't want to
allow Queen to a7 forcing an exchange of
Queens as the King is now opened a CD F
pawn moved so before playing Queens the
d4 Rashid has to play rook to f2 now
Queen to a7 will be pretty useless as
there is a rockin EV - black played h6
and the now Queen to d4 now as we've
said a queen a7 is pretty much useless
the screen captures on d6 is coming and
here was probably the last moment in the
game where you could have played where
sir gives he could have played rook to
d8 and continue the game but he decided
to play Bishop to e6 he developed and he
missed measurement eNOS next move so
feel free to pause the video here find
Najma dinos next move win this game for
white and truly have an excellent Sunday
so I will give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are truly
having an excellent Sunday and for those
of you who
one injured sure or maybe lazy on a
Sunday here in his Medina plate 'if I've
now you don't have to react to this
first of all your knight on f6 is under
attack if you move the knight for
example ninety five then you get
captures on d6 with Czech Queen captures
and now Knight to e4 attacking the Queen
Queen moves and now c4 attacking the
knight and now white just won the game
Knight has to move Queen captures on g7
and there's really not all that much you
can do here Queen f7 is coming you have
to block this simply rook captures and
now blacks blacks position simply falls
apart nice checks King moves Knight
checks here you capture now come c5 you
have to move the King from the
protection of the Queen King moves and
now Queen captures on c7 just one of the
variations that shows why you cannot
play Knight to d5 so in the game d
captures and if I was played but now
comes Rasheed's idea Queen to c5
checking the King and now forcing the
black King to stay in the center of the
board King yet and now comes rock
captures on f6 this is basically the
idea that head that was in the air all
along but you know the Queen had to be
here controlling this diagonal as the
rook is controlling this diagonal this
file so now there's really nothing to do
I don't know if a black resigned here
but I believe G captures was played and
only after Sergey has captured the the
exchanged sacrifice did he resign the
game why did he resign well also a nice
position for you to analyze it's not
very complicated but you know it will
surely improve your Sunday if you find
the right continuation for white so feel
free to do it for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations once again
your Sunday is truly spectacular here
nazar Medina of would play Knight to e4
and now it's all over
the queen is slicing all the way to FA
troop is slicing all the way to d8
Knight captures on f6 is coming this is
completely over there's a really no good
way to defend this if you block the
rooks file with better to d5 rook will
simply capture it as you can free
capture the Queen is undefended on c7 if
you try something like
Bishop to d7 if Bishop to d7 then comes
Knight f6 check King moves now comes
even Bishop to g4 completely piling up
on that Bishop on d7 as its pinned and
here there's really nothing to do
captures and after you tried to run away
it's all over I discovered check King
goes here and our room d7 will win you
the Queen so basically the only perhaps
reasonable move would be Queen to e7 but
now you get Queen captures and c6 with
the check King moves Queen captures an
a8 with check King moves and now you can
simply capture here and you are up a
whole a whole night and the pawn but you
know even even without the extra piece
the three the three connected passed
pawns would we need the game so yeah
after this G captures on f6 even without
playing Knight to e4 Vladimir in materia
which Cegavske resigned the game and a
beautiful beautiful victory for a
Rashida Schmidt Dean of so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it once
again very interested how the game will
turn out answer on Saturday so yeah best
of luck to everyone so I do hope you
enjoyed it and as I always say after
Anna Schmidt Univ game you know do share
the name of Russian is Mandino with your
friends and family you know show them a
couple of games Rashid played you know
they will surely enjoy it and then they
will show show it to all of their
friends and then you know one day
perhaps Rashid nurse Medina will be
granted the title of Grand Master and
also I will put a link in the
description below with some previous
videos from Russian and you know I have
an entire playlist so if you like Rashid
if you like his style
I mean who doesn't you know feel free to
check out those as well so yeah I would
like to thank Brian griffey and Paul me
for a contribution to my channel think a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you tomorrow with another nice ninja
meeting of game to brighten your day